Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters in another episode of Cutters Clinic Live.
Today we have a very special guest, Nathan Crane. We're going to introduce you to him,
introduce you to his whole like documentary that he created, some books that he's written,
his online community that he's just launched, which sounds exciting, just not done
specifically briefly. And I want to ask you more questions about that because I think as we were
discussing that in today's age with the whole COVID thing going on, everybody is very isolated
and there's a huge danger in that. We're not, or no longer a community of people that are connected
with one another. We need to reintroduce that somehow where we do have that connection,
unfortunately not the physical connection, but some way electronically where we don't feel so
isolated and low. Let's dive right into that. Nathan, thank you for being on today. What is your new
online community and explain that a little bit to us? Yeah, well thanks Dr. Connors for having
me on. Thanks for the great work you do. As we were talking just briefly offline, you know, the
both the positive and negative of our current time, right? The positive, we can reach millions of
people around the world through this great technology and share this information in ways that have
never been shared before, you know, life changing, life saving information that can reach somebody,
you know, at the click of a button, they can go online and access your podcast, join my membership,
watch a documentary, attend an event and learn more in a few hours than human beings we ever could
before, ever in human history, right? Because we used to have to find a master and apprentice with
that mastery and spend years and years with that master learning from them until we ourselves became
the master. And now, you know, with a few typings on the keyboard, we can find the answers
about everything we want. That's a positive of our time. The negative of our time, right, is that
not all information is created equal. And it's one of the reasons that I actually opened up what I
call the Health and Healing Club. And the Health and Healing Club is, you know, I've been in
natural health for about 15 years after going through, you know, my own health challenges and addiction
homelessness and things like that. I dove into natural health and started learning and experimenting
everything I could about living a healthy, natural, vital, vibrant, happy life and learning and
sharing as I went along. And along that journey, you find a lot of conflicting information, right?
The more you research, the more conflicting information you'll find that will support anybody's
theory or thought. The more that you interview experts, you learn from other speakers, from other
doctors, from other, you know, what we would consider experts in health. The more you find out that
the information is conflicting in a lot of cases. And what I found out along the way is that,
you know, there are three main reasons why we fear something like cancer, right? And the
three main reasons is one, we either don't have enough information, right? We just don't know
enough about it. You don't understand cancer, what causes it, what its solutions are, what gets rid
of it. You're going to be afraid, right? Because we just don't understand it, so not enough information.
And that was my point. You can also search online and not find enough of the right information, right?
The first 20 pages of Google are all going to be, you know, listings from pharmaceutical companies and
from Mayo Clinic and from, you know, conventional therapeutic approaches, right? You've got to go deep
to find anything beyond our, you know, conventional approach to cancer or any disease if you're
searching online now. So you have to dig a lot deeper than that. The second reason we fear something
like cancer is because of too much information. You know, I've been producing summits and conferences
and documentaries and writing books and masterclass and teaching nine months of masterclass coming up
for years now. And, you know, 15 years in natural health field, eight years dedicated specifically
to cancer. And someone may attend an event I do that has 60 world leading experts. And if you try
listening to all 60 at once, you would have information overload. That's the truth, right? But we don't
put 60 there. So that somebody listens to all 60 at once. We put 60 there so that you can find the
information you need in that moment to help you further along your path a little bit further.
And so too much information can be a challenge and people, you know, we get overloaded and then we do
nothing, right? So it's finding the right balance and information. And then the third reason we really
fear is because of misinformation, we've been told one thing when maybe that thing's not the complete
truth. And not necessarily that person was trying to mislead us, right? I think most doctors,
most experts, most health teachers are trying to do the right thing. They're trying to help people.
I really believe that in my heart that they most people helping people with cancer,
any chronic disease really care about them and really want to help them. But they themselves may not have
all of the information, right? And so they may be spreading misinformation unintentionally. And that
itself leads us to fear something like cancer, right? Because we may hear something, you know,
ketogenic is the cure for cancer. And then over here, no, ketogenic is the worst thing for you.
It's going to cause diabetes. And it's not going to help your cancer. And cancer can switch to ketones
from glucose as a fuel source. And so then someone goes, oh my god, you know, what do I do? I don't do
anything because I don't know who to trust, right? And so that's actually the reason I started
the Health and Healing Club was because through thousands of hours of personal research, hundreds
and hundreds of interviews, looking at hundreds and hundreds of scientific studies, you know,
interviewing the people who overcome cancer and diving in deep and saying, what exactly did you do?
Starting to look at the commonalities, the patterns, the foundations, the principles,
eventually, you know, over 15 years now, I came to a point of like, okay, it's a lot easier for me
now to decipher between what really seems effective and what doesn't, what really seems true and what
seems, you know, maybe like a half to what is really working for people and what's not. And so I took
the best of all that content and interviews and research and we put it into this membership site
that anyone can access anywhere in the world. And then we're bringing in new faculty members
and people I've worked with for years, the world eating experts of the top experts in the world
that work hands on with cancer patients day in and day out for years, for decades, thousands and
thousands of cancer patients actually seeing what works and what doesn't work. And then we bring
them on and we interview them and our members get to ask them questions and get their, you know,
most pressing health questions answered, you know, every two weeks we have our faculty team coming
in answering these questions. So it's really a membership that was designed to help people decipher
through all the misinformation, the lack of information, the information overload and get people
more of not only a sense of a community but belonging but a sense of, okay, I can actually be more
empowered now, I can feel more confident, I can actually have some real solutions I can trust in
that can help me on my journey forward in not only preventing cancer but, but, you know,
hopefully reversing cancer. Well, that's fantastic. I see that third point so evident with
our patients, you know, we talk to patients they, we feel like the misinformation that they get
or the disinformation that they get from standards of care, whether or not give it any other options,
okay, this is what we have to do. We have to surgery or chemo therapy or radiation, you know,
immunotherapy, that's the only tools in the tool bag and that if the patients even remotely suggest
using another approach, even adjunctively, they're just shot down completely. And that's kind of the
cancel culture that we live in but the cancel culture within standards of care has been going on a
lot longer than the last year, where everything else is canceled out because their way is the only way.
And it's, people get frustrated with that but they also, when you talk about those first two
fears, you tie those all together, people are scared to death, they kind of are in shock when they hear
the C word with their diagnosis and it's easy for them to out of those levels of fear that you
just described to follow down a path that maybe if they would have stopped and thought about it a little
bit longer. And, you know, scripture says there's there's wisdom with a multitude of counselors where
you just take a step back and you start looking at what other people are saying that maybe you can make
more rational decisions and some people regret the decision that they made when they're ushered out of
pathway that they didn't really have a chance to think about. Absolutely. You know, I'm sure you work with
a lot of people who have experienced that exact same experience every single day. I've certainly met
many of them and talked to many of them and interviewed them as well. I actually had a pre-interview with
Steve Wallace yesterday and he is going, I'm going to do a full-length interview with him for my
upcoming master class called Becoming Cancer Free. And, you know, his exact story is exactly what you
just said. You know, he had stage four, Carson Nome, he had a tumor right here on his neck. He had
spread to lymph nodes and, you know, he went to conventional oncologists and they said, you know,
we need to cut this out of you right away. So he thought, okay, yeah, let's get rid of it. Let's do
the surgery, right? So they did the surgery, they removed the tumor, they removed maybe eight or
nine lymph nodes. And then, you know, the follow-up, you know, they had seen some hot spots, they had
assumed it was spreading by that point stage four. It does spread by that point, right? And so they
said, okay, now we need to do the follow-up chemotherapy and radiation. And so something had just
told him intuitively, internally, no, I don't think I want to do that, you know, and they were really
pushing for it as they do. And he decided against it and started seeking an integrative approach,
a more natural holistic approach, started educating himself, going to different clinics, he ended up
finding the Center for New Medicine, which is a colleague of mine, Dr. Liar and Caneli. They were,
you know, they've had over 75,000 patients that they've treated in her career. And they do an
integrative approach. You do some lotus IPT and some, you know, they will recommend surgery when it's
needed, but they do a lot of natural holistic therapies as well. And so he just kind of resonated with
that a lot more even though he didn't fully understand it, right? But he was listening, like you say,
he was listening to that voice within, whether being guided, divinely guided by spirit, or, you
know, what, what have you, but it was his own voice he was listening to, which is so important when
making decisions, life changing decisions for our health that we sit back, like you said, and we,
we take some time, get other guidance, listen to other experts, get additional opinions and sit
inside ourselves and ask ourselves those questions and sit and take some time to, to really reflect
and to find out what path is best for us. And, and he's so lucky that he did that because now this
is seven years later, I'm talking to him. Not only has his circulating tumor cell count continuously
gone down, but his other cancer markers have continuously gone down. You wouldn't say that he's
totally cancer-free today, but all of his count, all of his markers, his biomarkers have continued to
go down, continued to go down. The most important thing is he has not lost any quality of life whatsoever.
And that's the key, right? The problem is, is if we, if we just immediately jump into chemotherapy
and radiation, immediately quality of life is going to be drastically impacted. We know that
your immune system gets destroyed, your body starts falling apart from the inside out. You're killing
your, but you're not only killing the cancer, but you're killing everything good about your body as well.
And it's not a, you know, I'm not saying you have to avoid chemotherapy and radiation. I'm just
saying, you know, it's important to understand all of your options, right? It's important to understand
what options you really have. And so since he went down a more holistic integrative approach,
he has kept a very good, high quality of life. He says he has energy, he's healthy, he feels
great. He gets to live his life the way he wants to. You know, he's obviously changed his diet
in his lifestyle and exercises and eats better. It does a lot of things that we know you need to do
to take back control of your health, but he didn't have that quality of, of life loss. Like, you know,
the thing that really sent me down, the path of wanting to help people with cancers. When I saw my
own grandpa go through cancer, not really cancer, but chemotherapy and radiation. I saw it completely
destroy him. He just put him in tremendous pain. He couldn't even get up to go to the bathroom without
saying it was just, you know, so much pain, you know, the vomiting, the nausea, the sickness. And then
it was shortly after that that he passed away. And it really, you know, was the treatment that took
his life. And, you know, I wished and hoped at the time that I knew more about cancer and that I
could help him, but I couldn't. And I didn't. And I was afraid just like, you know, most people are
today. And that sent me down this path, this mission, this just, you know, desire to learn everything I
possibly can so that I can not only protect myself and my family, but help everybody else out there
who wants to, you know, do whatever they can to not only extend their life, but add more
quality of life to that extension, add more quality of life to their years. And in the process, maybe
you end up like a lot of the people that I've had the chance of getting to interview who did reverse
stage 4 cancer following, you know, a holistic or an integrative approach. Yeah, you made mention of not
the biggest reason why people look at an integrative approach is that, well, at least that person is because they've had family
members that have had bad experiences doing instead of caring. Yeah. And many times that's the thing that
shakes the person up a little bit because I don't know, I think, you know, we have come off of this Marcus
well, the mentality that we trust everything that our doctor says. But when we hear a serious diagnosis,
we contend to fall back into that really quickly. And I describe it as there's a part of us as humans that
don't want to take responsibility for grave things. Like, you have cancer. Oh my gosh. Well, I don't want
to take responsibility for that because I might screw it up. So I'm going to just leave it in my
oncologist hands and trust them fully. And then many people, not everybody, but many people that do that
regret it terribly afterwards. The ones that tend not to do that, at least the ones that we hear about,
the people that call us often are ones that, well, I'm not going to do that approach because I saw my mom
go through it or I saw my sister go through it. And it didn't end well. Or they might still be alive,
but they suffered horribly. They still suffer horribly from it. I just talked to somebody yesterday
that was like, she was in our case review, that's our first conversation that I have with them. Sometimes
they don't, you know, explore a website, you know, in depth, and they might feel like I might push
them towards the standards of care too, because of course, I'm a doctor. So that's what I'm going to do.
And she was immediately defensive that I am not going to do standards of care. I would rather
die earlier and live a healthier life up to that point than suffer through chemo and live longer.
And I understand that's not always true. And of course, I am an integrated practitioner,
meaning that I'm not against chemotherapy, I'm just against unwise use of it and or using it because
you think that's the only option that you have. So it's great that more people are opening their
eyes to integrate it here. But in the same sense, it's sad that you see that split almost, you know,
that that doesn't need to be, I have often said, our clinic and clinics like ours really should
be attached to Mayo Clinic. We should be working together. If we really care about patient care,
don't we want to do whatever best for the patient, whether it be surgery and, you know, alternative
care or chemo and alternative care should we do whatever is the best thing for the patient,
is that the answer versus this dogmatic approach that we're stuck on because of
our trading or our financial ties, that's saddens me.
It's true. I mean, it's exact same thing we see going on right now with this pandemic, this virus,
this COVID around the world, right? I mean, it's turned into so much more about a political
affiliation and a political approach than it is about the actual health and well-being of the
population. And wherever somebody stands on this side of COVID, it is clearly a strong
delineation separation between people who say, you know, give me the vaccine, give me five shots
of the vaccine, I'm going to wear two masks every day, I'm going to lock myself in my house because
I know I'm saving lives, right? And it's absolutely believe it and they are 100% in alignment with
that. And there's the other side, it is so the opposite, the extreme that says, absolutely not,
I will not wear a mask because I've been proven not to work, I will not take vaccines because they
can cause all kinds of health problems, including death. And I will not lock myself inside because
actually outside I need to breathe fresh air and get vitamin D and all these other things.
And you don't find a lot of people in the middle there, certainly I haven't yet, I'm sure there
are some, but it seems that people have really picked a side on this and it's quite extreme.
And it's been that way for cancer for way too long, people have picked a side, it's either
conventional, alopathic medical approach is the only approach. Or naturopathic, no conventional medicine,
all diet and lifestyle is the only approach. And I am in a 100% agreement with you, I think the only
way forward as a society is that we have to come together and work together to say, what are the
most effective solutions for dealing with whatever the health challenge is and implement those
no matter what your bias may be or what your political influence may be or what your financial ties
may be. We have to come together for the betterment of the individual, for the cancer patient,
for the person dealing with the chronic health challenge or who has been impacted by the viral
infection. One of the challenges you see in this and this become very clear to me of where our
government stands is in over a year now of this viral pandemic, not once have you ever seen our
government or our mainstream media or our leaders of this nation or any nation that I've seen so far
come out publicly and say, look, you need to take care of your immune system, you need to eat healthier,
you need to do what whether you get the vaccine or not whether you wear masks or not whether
you need to focus on your health as an individual as a family, you know, we're going to put together
programs for you to take care of your immune system because we know viruses just like cancer will
only give you symptoms or problems if you have a weak immune system. We know the cure to cancer is
a strong immune system, right? Dr. Thomas Lodi says it's so clearly in my documentary and it's been
validated again and again. If you have a fully functioning very strong immune system, you will not have
a cancer diagnosis because your body's doing what's designed to do and getting rid of those cancer
cells every single day through the lymphatic system, through, you know, T cells and B cells and all the
beautiful functions of our immune system that removes cancer cells from our body every single day.
The same is true for any viral infection. You know, why is somebody the difference is cancer you make
from internally, you know, viruses you catch from externally, right? That's so that's a big difference
we need to understand. You don't catch cancer even though we kind of look at it that way. So
consciousness and society is like, oh, it's something I got. I got cancer. No, you made cancer. Your
body's been making it for many years. You just now discovered it, right? Versus, yeah, we can breathe
in a virus, but it affects the body in very similar ways. If your immune system is strong and it's
fully functioning, you may have a few symptoms or no symptoms at all, but your adaptive immune system
and your immune system are going to kick in and they're going to knock that thing, you know, they
see a kick and overdrive and knock that virus out of your body and you're going to be fine, right?
But that's why we know the latest statistics for COVID, for example, which was, I can't remember the
exact percentage. Now I saw it a while back. It was like 96%, something I got very high percent, maybe
99% of people who've died from COVID had three or more co-morbidities, meaning their immune system was
already totally weakened. They already had cancer, autoimmune disease or diabetes or
combination of all three. They had other, you know, health challenges going on and then the virus was
just the, the straw that broke the camel's back, right? So no matter what we're dealing with, we've
got to go back to the immune system and that's what an integrative approach should look like, you know,
Mayo Clinic, these other clinics out there that have been primarily conventional medicine for
so long, they are now opening integrative divisions. The problem with that so far in my opinion is that
those are marketing employees to reach a larger demographic of people. How could you?
You're just trying to piggyback on everything that we're doing.
You know, because you go and look at those integrative centers and it's like what do they really
offer? You know, they're not really offering much. You know, they have a little room that you can go
over and they call it a meditation room and go to your meditation over there. It's a little
locked away room in the corner, you know, or they have, you know, maybe they don't even have PMF
devices in most of these places, but say they do, maybe they have a PMF device and you can use that
for like an hour. And that's about it. They might have a couple two or three things. In most of them,
now there are some that are, you know, really advancing and moving forward, but most of them are not
doing much in terms of actual integrative care. So that's what I love about what you're doing is you're
really focused on truly integrative care. It's looking at the best of what actually works from all
worlds, ancient medicine, indigenous medicine, western medicine, eastern medicine, you know, diet and
nutrition lifestyle. Let's, let's do all of it because that's what it takes, right? It takes treating the
the whole human being. As I say, the mind, body, emotion, spirit, relationships, environment,
all of it. We have to treat all of it. If you would just take one herb or one capsule or one drug
thinking it's going to cure you, I'm sorry, but it's just, it's not going to happen. We have to do
it from a fully integrative approach. And the reason I say that is because all the evidence suggests
that in all the people I've interviewed who have reversed stage 4 cancers and are living
many years past their expiration date, their prognosis, every single one of them has all of these
commonalities amongst them. Yeah, I would totally agree. Yep. And speaking to get on, you're
saying that why hasn't the government shared information on building your immune system and improving
your health as the number one responsibility of each individual to be able to overcome disease,
whether it be a viral pandemic or whether it be cancer, heart disease, the number one in two
killers in the United States, you have to wonder, it makes people distrust the government,
especially when they've got even, you know, four steps further than any so many medical doctors
who have come out to speak that way and to say those very things that are in standards of care,
their videos have been taken off of YouTube and you know, you can't even find them. And good to say,
now that we mentioned the big C word COVID in this video, we probably, this video might not stay on
YouTube very long. It's unfortunate it makes people distrust the government even more. And then the
people that aren't the seekers of information and the diggers to find videos like this and
and other, you know, information that gives them the the hands on ability to help heal themselves.
Those people are just even empowered more to the other side. Well, see there's no information on that.
I googled it and I searched through the first 20 pages as you mentioned it. It was all data on a
drug or data on something else. It's unfortunate that dig tech is censoring all this stuff and making
our problem even more difficult to get information to people. And that's why I love about you and
so many people like you and I that are trying to get information out so that people can be helped. And
I've said it for decades. We can't help everybody in our clinic. That's why we give away our books for
free. That's why we give away our stuff for free. It's like I just want to help people that could
never come to us. And so I love about your website. You can download your books and download your stuff
and watch your videos and you're just trying to help people. I guess, I guess that's what it's all
about. That's what people need to see the difference in the sides that way.
Absolutely. And that's I think we're coming to a precipice very soon of what is truly important
for the human being, for the individual. What is really important for us as a human being? Is it
my health? Is it my longevity? Is it my well-being? Is it my sense of joy and happiness in my life? Is it
my sense of fulfillment in meaning? Right? You and I, we feel so much great meaning from service
to others, from sharing and giving and helping and seeing people change their life. I think all
human beings get a sense of joy and meaning and purpose when you help others in any way that you
possibly can. Right? Or is it convenience? I want more convenience. I want more comfort. I want more
technology. I want more control over me, less me having to do less decision-making. Right? There's
this, if you watch the information about the great reset and the information about from the world
economic forum and what they're projecting for the future of humanity, that's everybody here tuning in.
This is what they want for you and this is why we have to question, is this what we want for us?
Is they want for us to sit at home, and this is public. It's not some conspiracy thing. You can find
them publicly speaking about it online. Those videos aren't censored by the way. Even though our
videos are getting censored, those aren't. So you can find them easily. And what they want for you,
what they want for us, is to sit at home, be surrounded by all kinds of smart technology, and have
that technology make our decisions for us. They want that technology to make your decisions for you.
What they say is it will make your life so much easier, where you can just wake up and ask your
smart device, what should I do today? And your smart device will tell you what you should do today.
And it might tell you, go get a vaccine. It might tell you, you know, go get a fast food hamburger
at Joe's restaurant. It might tell you, stay home because it's dangerous outside. It might tell you,
you know, the medical treatment for the day, and that's the only one, and natural health doesn't count.
Don't listen to it, right? Whatever it's going to tell you, what they want for us is for us to do
less thinking. So they can do our thinking for us. Again, this is not conspiracy. This is public
information of these leaders, when the world economic forum publicly saying, and these are the
tech giants of the world, that are really controlling the world at this point, as they want a technocratic
society, not only the United States, but globally, where government is ran by technocrats. It's ran
for the greater betterment of the technology companies and the billionaires at the expense of us
individual human beings, just doing whatever they tell us to do. But they say and go watch the
great reset video. They say, but they say in 2030, you will own nothing, but you will be happy.
Right? They're trying to put this message across to say, like, you won't own anything. You don't
have to make decisions for yourself or your health anymore. We'll do all that for you. You just have
an easy, relaxed life. You don't have to worry about any of it. And you'll be happy, by the way.
So it's this brainwashing. It's this conditioning. It's happening. That's why I say we're at this
precipice. We're at this breaking point right now. And in the next few years, where we have to decide
what we truly want for ourselves. Do we want sovereignty? Do we want sovereignty and health
freedom? The freedom to choose what we can and can't, what we decide to put in our bodies and what we
want forced vaccinations. Do we want forced stay at home orders? Do we want forced treatments for
cancer? Like they've been doing, you know, the child, and I believe it was in California a number
of years back, they took from the parents and forced that child to get chemotherapy against the
parents wishes. Do we want more of that? You know, or do we want our freedom, our sovereignty,
our ability to think and choose and research for ourselves, our freedom to put the chemicals in
our body or not put them in our body, the freedom to put the herbs in our body or not put them in
our body. I'll tell you what, I am voting and standing with the people who want the freedom,
the sovereignty to choose what is right for us. And each of us have to choose that for ourselves.
And to do that, we have to educate ourselves. I think your audience is probably a very educated
audience. I know you do these podcasts and you put out a lot of good information through your website.
So I think most people tuning in are in alignment with, you know, a more natural holistic or integrative
approach is probably a better approach for them when deciding, you know, how to take care of
their health for the long term. But again, a lot of people don't even have access to that information
yet. So I do want to encourage everyone tuning in, not only share this video and share it as far
and why as you possibly can on every social media site and with friends and family and email,
but share Dr. Conner's website, his books, his blog, his podcast, with as many people as you can
every day, because it is so important with the censorship that's happening, as you mention,
from this ever growing technocratic, you know, censorship of honestly, let's face it, we're heading
towards fascism. If we don't do something about it, the information is not reaching the people
who need it, who it could save their lives unless people like you who are tuning in are sharing
this with as many people as possible. So, you know, it's up to us. I guess that's my point,
and I'll get off my soapbox here for a second because I got a little passionate there about what we're
going through because I've spent a lot of time being censored, being the person who's being censored
and watching my colleagues being censored and watching people's, you know, with millions of followers,
their entire social media accounts being deleted right now for sharing evidence-based
research coming out of PubMed and our most respected journals, getting censored because it's not
going along with the mainstream narrative that's being pumped out by, you know, this is ever-growing
technocratic, you know, government and a fascist government that's happening unfortunately. So,
it's up to each one of us. We must learn, educate, continue to educate ourselves, learn as much as we
can through resources like this, through ConnorsClinic.com, through this podcast, through the Health
and Healing Club, but then share that with as many people as we possibly can. Well, they said,
I could not agree more, and if you get me on my soapbox, I get a scream just as long. It is so
frustrating. I've been doing this 35 years in practice this year, and, you know, remember having
small little seminars teaching people about vitamin C, to know we could have these podcasts and go
live to millions of people. But still, we've been censored, our videos have been censored, and we need
people to take a stand. Whether it's just a simple stand, I'm not going to wear a bag or a simple stand
and share information on why I'm not going to get the vaccine. The point isn't the vaccine
or the mass. The point is having the freedom to choose. And we are losing that in this country
so rapidly that it's a little scary, in a sense, but it takes every single person who believes in
health freedom, even if you want to get the vaccine, that you believe that you have a freedom of choice
that you could use the wisdom that God gave you to make your own decisions. And when you lose
the ability to make your own decisions about your health care, you're going to lose very rapidly
decision to make about what you can eat, what you can buy, what you can, how you can spend your
money. And it's just going to go right down this very slippery slope. So I would agree with you.
We need to share this information. I just thanks so much for having
be it available. I would love to have you on again, Nathan, if you're willing.
I love it when you get out of your soapbox. It's not just me screaming to my patients either.
They can see there's other crazy people out there too that believe the same way.
There's can be comfort in them. It's the crazy ones that have always helped move humanity forward,
right? I think everyone tuning in here has a little bit of that craziness. And the good crazy is
what we're talking about, right? And that's what we need. We need that conviction, that craziness,
that little bit of, you know, confidence and courage. Really, it's courage in a time of silencing
and punishment to stand up against tyranny and say, look, we've got to come together and fight for
what's right. What's right for ourselves, for our children. You know, I have two young children.
I'm thinking about what's right for them. And I'm thinking about what's right for their children
and their children. And so, you know, we just sit back and don't do anything. Guess what? The people
who want to control us and have more power are going to certainly take it because when has
absolute power never absolutely corrupted, right? We know that it always happens unless you and I
stand up and do something about it. Well, Nathan, your website, NathanCRA8.com. I encourage
everybody to go to that. We'll have links on this for everyone with the links on the blog.
Thank you for being a part of our podcast today. And I'm going to be on your cancer.
What do you call it again? Sorry. Like there. Yeah, summit. I'm coming summit. Yeah.
That's going to be exciting. Look forward to that. And I want to give everyone actually at NathanCRA8.com,
we did put a free ebook there for everybody tuning in here that can go there and download absolutely
free. It's called the five natural pillars for helping prevent reverse cancer. You can download that
absolutely free at NathanCRA8.com. And yeah, Dr. Connors, thank you so much. Thank you for doing the
great work you do and for being, you know, really a pioneer in the field. You've been doing this
a long time. And I really am honored and humbled to, you know, be able to speak with your community
here today. So thank you. All right. Thank you so much. Bye bye.